hey what's up mkbhd here
okay so the whole
folding screen thing still pretty new
we're maybe two years into seeing real
devices that are shipping with folding
screens in them but yet still there's a
lot of questions about hey are these
really a future is this actually where
we're gonna go and can this apply to
more than just phones so this this is
the world's first foldable oled
laptop
but also the world's first foldable oled
tablet in a lot of ways too most of the
time but the whole point is this is
pushing that technology basically to its
size limits at this point and so from it
we can learn a lot about where the tech
is right now so shout out to lenovo for
sponsoring this video for this showcase
to have a first look at the thinkpad x1
fold so i've already said this folding
display tech is definitely in its
infancy so building an entire machine
around it no matter what size is going
to be extremely bleeding edge and we see
that in all the folding phones and the
razor from motorola and the galaxy fold
the question is
is it worth exploring a bigger scale
version of it so this is what that looks
like right now so this is a 13.3 inch
oled display about the size of a large
tablet but it folds right in half and so
that becomes the size of like a small
laptop it turns it into two 9.6 inch
screens when it's folded so now just
looking around this thing it's quite the
combination of premium materials and
also bleeding edge workarounds if you
will like the the whole thing is wrapped
in leather and if i'm being honest it
looks really nice when closed the
leather sleeve kind of slides into place
around the hinge slides out when it's
open
that part is nice and when it's fully
open you can pop out this kickstand on
the back with this red felt material
inside
i mean they're really playing well to my
red and black habit but this part is
very well considered it looks great the
hard part though is the actual folding
screen part so when you look inside you
see the bezels the size of which really
aren't a problem at all but what's
unique here is they're a rubberized
material and they're sort of raised up
and that with an accordion mechanism in
the middle hides the complexity of that
hinge that's making it possible but that
right there
is the hardest part like we already saw
it took samsung two generations to get
the hinge weight right on their tiny
galaxy fold so it takes a lot of
engineering to get the hinge weight
right in a bigger laptop version of it
which is arguably even more important
but after that it does
open and close it opens a hundred
percent flat and it closes to
nearly gapless but i'll get to why it's
like this in a second
some other fun pieces though it has a
power button and volume rockers over
here on the side and there's a light
behind the power button there's two
usb-c ports both of which are fully
functional so you can charge it through
either one depending on where you're
sitting or how you're holding it it has
optional 5g built in and up to one
terabyte nvme ssd
and it actually has pen support most
foldable displays so far have been
explicitly very fragile and they don't
have pen support they're delicate and
scratch easily but this one is not one
of those so it has an optional digital
pen that you can use to sign documents
or draw things or even just move around
the ui whatever you want if you're into
that so why would you want
this like laptops are fine they're
pretty good as they are right why would
you want a future version of this
instead of that well for lenovo it's all
about the different postures that this
can be in so again like the fold i guess
i'll kind of keep referring to the fold
because it's the one we all know about
but
that in its theoretical best case can be
a phone
and
a tablet
and so again because of the postures
this can be in this is theoretically in
its best version
both a tablet
and a laptop so this guy here is running
windows 10 as you can tell so all the
usage is on an os that's already running
pretty well with touch but i'd also be
interested in seeing how an android
version could possibly handle this form
factor but this is tablet mode so big
tall display 2048 by 1536 resolution
it's a bit thicker overall than a normal
tablet but it's also bigger overall than
a normal tablet it's a 13-inch oled
display so that's your benefit for your
video watching your multitasking your
virtual keyboards typing your browsing
everything here is all bigger and of
course you can even go vertical with it
so maybe there's some tall documents
maybe there's some vertical videos
you're trying to watch maybe you just
like that vertical tablet life but all
that works fine
but again the bonus of the kickstand
here is if you're watching like a video
on youtube or a movie or something is
that you have a screen basically the
size of a 13 inch laptop without nearly
as much weight or mass as a typical 13
inch laptop so that would be my number
one use for this particular version
imagine watching videos on a plane tray
table at a comfortable distance without
worrying about the keyboard so that's
tablet mode which is sweet but then you
can also of course
fold it in half but there's actually a
version where you stop folding halfway
and it's in this sort of
well they call it book mode
you can see why right so at this point
you kind of start to mentally separate
these as two separate screens at the
same time as the software recognizes all
right this is becoming two separate
screens so you can do reading on one
side taking notes on the other or really
just any multitasking side by side you
can have a zoom call on one side and
writing or whatever note taking on the
other so for some remote podcast stuff
i've done zoom on one side and then
audio recording app and then notes on
the other it's a lot of side by side
stuff plus there's a bonus of some apps
that when they work well we'll let you
just use the whole thing as an actual
book which is kind of sweet but what
you're really on your way towards here
is the laptop modes now like i mentioned
at the beginning lenovo built an entire
pc here like this is a windows computer
there's a one terabyte ssd an intel cpu
eight gigs of ram there's fans it's the
whole thing so you do have a
full-fledged desktop experience on the
sideways display just
all touch screen but the thing about
laptops is once you get to this place
usually you want to do a lot of
typing and yes of course sure you can
have a virtual keyboard and there's
multi-touch and it's really responsive
and maybe you even add haptics someday
but there's always just something
better about having a real
tactile keyboard
but it turns out
lenovo basically agrees with me on that
because they did build one for the x1
fold and it's literally an ultra thin
bluetooth keyboard with magnets in it
that snaps into place over half of the
display you turn it on you connect it
and boom the ui snaps to the top half of
the screen and now
really it's acting exactly like a normal
laptop you're word processing writing
emails whatever it is you're into with
that keyboard it even has an actual
trackpad and as far as i can tell there
is almost zero latency which is
impressive over bluetooth so to the
point where it's just as functional as a
laptop albeit slightly smaller like a
nine to ten inch laptop so the
keyboard's a little more compact the
screen's a little smaller but it's
definitely still very usable and
significantly better than digital typing
would be and this is actually one of
those cases where the rubberized bezels
helps because they keep the keyboard in
place along with those magnets
and then yeah best part is when you're
done if you just want to pack it up and
store it the keyboard can stay inside
and the laptop closes perfectly gapless
and flat
that is nice so that's definitely a lot
but i'm fascinated by this thing now it
is 3 000 bucks so it's definitely not
for everyone but the upside of having
foldables like this existing and coming
out is the more we have
talented people working on making
foldable stuff good
the better they actually get over time
and the more we're working towards that
dream of having an actual
two-in-one where really can be both of
those form factors well and a big part
of this is getting developers in on
making quality apps that take advantage
of the folding display thing
which is i mean it's still early stages
for that that's the whole point and
there's not a whole lot of great apps
doing that yet in i was going to say the
microsoft store or really any store at
this point so the only way to change
that
is to start by making good foldable
stuff and get that ball rolling but then
hopefully the cycle kind of feeds itself
the tech gets better
you know the chips get better the
batteries get better this whole profile
gets slimmer and even more refined maybe
you don't need the fan vents anymore
would you be into that
let me know in the comment section below
would you rather have a laptop and a
tablet and a phone or maybe a
convertible somewhere in between those
either way thanks for watching shout out
to lenovo again for sponsoring this
video for the thinkpad x1 and i'll leave
all the links relevant below if you want
to check it out
all right
catch you guys the next one
peace